welcome to this video con tourists from
Sweden
yeah I'm sticking with you for your fire
oops yep so what is he doing there the
good old Vienna again I can check only
four but that's not a line I know too
well and four I recently lost to this
recently yeah recently is a bit much but
you should have checked this I should
have checked this bedlam okay
let's just play something I cannot spend
two minutes here trying to find that
lost against exactly this move order
some weeks ago but I forgot to check it
and then someone told me that that it
was some in a recent book I really hate
that if I am if I fare badly against an
opening and then forget to look it up I
mean I'm not saying that this is bad for
Y that's just it just that you when you
recognize you have a hole there in your
repertoire you should fix it and I
forgot that I really forgot that okay at
least he cannot cancel I mean this is
not an easy position okay what is he
doing here don't get it h-34 1994 was
seem problematic to him okay I wonder if
I should go Knight 86 here 986 yeah
maybe if he takes it I have Bishop b7
coming and I can probably just win the
d5 pawn back night before it's
definitely a threat you can play a3 of
course but this is slow yep I thought
Bishop b6 495 maybe let's do that not
spend more time intending to go 95 looks
like B force may be possible looks looks
a bit bonkers but it makes my night look
a bit stupid there yeah maybe maybe
before it's not bad at all
okay he decided to take it and possibly
return the pole and I thought I will
just win the pawn back now I wonder now
yeah let's play let's just play that if
I just get the pawn back on d5 I cannot
be in bad shape
don't think so you will probably Castle
long and I'm grabbing this pawn it's
them it's a bishop pair in a wide open
position and I'm pretty well developed
so yeah it looks pretty good
not sure there wow that's a move it
looks extremely problematic putting this
night into the search this hanging kind
of situation okay maybe just night
before I was something better Queen f6
maybe but okay this is this is simple
and let's just keep it simple a before
Queen D form just for activation and
possible Queen trade Queen trade should
be okay for me with my bishops pointing
towards his King side pawns if he avoids
the trade like Queen g3 or something I
can take before probably I don't really
think he can punish me for that maybe
queen g3 also have something like queen
f2 simply trying to insist on them on
the Queen trade ways trading
okay what's what's best him g-force
maybe in the in the mix I can tribe
Bishop f-22 g3 we should have two G for
Bishop g3 rookie to Bishop f3 takes
Tiegs
yeah it's not bad let's try that the
pawns are really vulnerable only issues
I might lose something back on the Queen
side I have this this week for
instruction there Jeff
okay so look look there I can go here
continuing continuing to harass them but
you'll care for one now chance not so
I'm Bishop g2 care to is a bit
embarrassing so I have to go back let's
go here controlling controlling the
night yeah I'm a bishop is a bit off
site they're on h2 maybe no it's not
offside that's good
what is he doing Bishop f4 maybe okay
let's drop back we should therefore I
have Bishop g2 winning this pond and I'm
attacking before as well so it's a
double threat essentially
so Bishop she - right let's grab this
thing he cannot trap it oh we can miss
Bishop with with him Knight F - okay
didn't didn't see that one coming
maybe I don't know a 94 maybe it's
coming so I have to get my King in the
game anyway
Knight c4 yeah that's a bit of a problem
there should be two I overlooked that
but it's lucky you can go look f2
yeah I always have to be a bit careful
about my pawns them time warning yeah
I'm pushing those pawns this I don't
know if this is a good idea
mmm it should be five I don't know
opposite colored bishops and then I
don't know difficult with with this term
situation okay yeah go engine shake and
win the f5 pawn my king is quite active
I mean whenever after checking at five I
mean the Queen side is completely
completely safe I want the edge pawns as
a person if possible if the Queen side I
have no no no it's not it's not that
easy
check DRA Arthur
sorry guys this isn't is even clearer
draw let's check maybe it is a clear
draw but I want to want to look first
okay is sitting there and okay it's it
wrong game
yep I want to check to want to check
first with a couple of seconds but it is
a draw a blocks the H pawn and he's
blocking in the Queen side this time you
had me I don't know yeah I don't really
remember the other games Karen it was
always better for black of course with
the bishops but not sure if I missed
something something clear this this this
probably should be won by black maybe
this operation with bishop f2 wasn't
what sorry it wasn't good can just play
rook 88 or something of course
this Chairman Jack looks actor but it's
not really leading to much not sure if I
had had something clear though one issue
is always the vulnerable Queen side of
course rookie form that sets up that's
that's good that's a resource that I
didn't see at all yeah I was a bit
skeptical at his pawn baddest pawn there
and rightly so but I didn't find the
reason why it was a problem and this is
the reason that looks very problematic
for EM yeah okay III decided to go for
the opposite kind of bishops also
because it felt that is simpler to play
check but it's probably really just a
draw check yeah yeah it's it wrong I can
i really have no I have no way forward
the King blocks one pawn the bishop
keeps them other sytem in check so
correct draw them okay well thanks for
watching